hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to power wash simulator
i literally just woke up and i had to
play more i don't care what anyone says
i love this game and i just got the new
power washer and i have to use it it's
so
good and i've decided i made a decision
that like
soap is fine but universal cleaner
is cheating and it's too expensive
anyway like i i i'm not going to use the
soap because i love this uh this new
washer anyway because it just
blasts off lixian creep is family
friendly please it just blasts away
like oh my god look at it cuts right
through
oh it's like a dream like this would
probably be the
oh yeah that's a good approach
oh yeah wait i got the strategy oh my
god i got it
guys i got it oh i got it after all this
time
i finally figured it out i got the
strategy
oh this is how you do it okay all that
turning nonsense
no no you got to use the keyboard you
got to use the keyboard properly
if you don't you're never going to get
done with anything oh
that's nice this new god i'm not even
going to know what to do with myself
when i get the next upgrade of washer
it's going to be spoiling like it's
going to be as liv as if i have like
unlimited soap you know
and that's just cheating you know i
ain't about that this is about
it's about being meticulous this is
about being careful this is about
doing things right this is about doing
things by the book
you know you gotta do things by the book
or else you're never even gonna
get any satisfaction out of your life
oh my god record time
so freaking smooth
god that's some smooth work
i'm just in utter glee honor glee all
the time
i've never been happier yeah what does
it say about my life
either like i'm living life to the best
of my ability or i'm like really missing
something
hey i wasn't done hey
i wasn't done honestly this grime
doesn't look too uh
too intense see how this does oh my god
yeah
look at that just going away oh
like a dream like a dream
[Music]
oh my goodness now it's just like
everything is coming together
like i don't know what it is like uh in
the last episode there was something
about me in the playground that was just
like looking at the whole task and just
being like oh man this is so daunting
like i'll never get this done
but now i'm just like i'm cherishing
every moment every crack that i get to
blast away
like this mold that's going to be a
little pesky but you know
it's kind of like a challenge it just
erodes
it erodes finish her off
you mold don't stand a oh wait wait a
minute
wait i'm an idiot i wasn't even using my
i was using the other gun the whole time
i was just having a good time with a
regular gun
i didn't even real i was wondering why
the mold wasn't going away
oh i am
very stupid i guess it just goes to show
you that i would have been fine with the
normal gun on this job
oh but now oh look at that oh look at
that oh yeah
oh yeah oh never mind
i'm so stupid but also just like oh wow
look at this thing
it's so good guys it's so good i can't
ever recommend a game more than i can
remember this one
and i know it's not for everybody i
definitely know that this type of game
is not for everybody but
holy sh look at that
oh my god
[Music]
a lot of ways is like painting with
shadows because it's so crazy how you do
oh my god
just like seeing the perspective change
from one to another
like after you finish a job or finish uh
finish doing it from one angle like just
switching to another and being like holy
crap
like just seeing the difference is part
of the fun who would have thought like
what do you think game developers like
20 years ago
would think if they knew that this is
where gaming was coming to like this is
the culmination of all the efforts of
gaming and all the advances in
technology and whatnot
i mean great number one but also just
like
i don't know i think they might be a
little bit surprised
oh yeah i was missing this spot okay
never mind i was like ah man i don't
know where there would be that much more
on the
the railing but man i miss this ooh
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right um i want to get the front
first i want to get the front all
done all nice and done and then i'm
going to go
elsewhere later
[Music]
oh now we got now we got some power oh
yeah now see i was like
oh i thought i remember the the white
attachment actually doing a bit more uh
more dabblish to this thing and now i
see like oh yeah no there was
just wrong atta wrong hose
wrong washer not enough power
did you hear that weird
what weird rumbling noise
it's a volcano about to go what are you
talking about
false alarm jenny put the water okay
yeah okay
i'm just waiting for the moment when a
ghost actually does pop out of this
thing
i mean given that this place is kind of
next to a volcano which is something
lore wise that we did see
which i do want to explore i want a deep
dive video from matpat about the
lore of power wash simulator given that
there is a volcano nearby
i guess a lot of this schmutz does make
a bit more sense
and if ever there was a place to have a
power washing business it would be
near a volcano so uh
yeah it makes sense it makes sense but
also the ghosts like i really want to
know about the ghosts like
how many how many kids were murdered in
this town
how many kids exploded into a glorious
explosion of poop and mud
man my photoshop skills of being able to
like draw with my mouse
are kind of coming in handy with like
doing straight lines and stuff like that
like really following edges whereas
normally i would believe that this would
like be uh
a pain in the ass for a lot of people
but for me i've been doing it so long
like every thumbnail i've ever made i
made with my
mouse i don't use styluses or anything
so and i do a lot of like actual drawing
and cutting out and like
i'll like actually carve out images with
just my hand so um
i've done this before man some of these
spots are tough even for the new one
i don't know what kind of bird shot on
this but they must add a mixture of
concrete and rocks
i also got to remember it is a proximity
thing so there is like if you're closer
to it you know it does more
like that is definitely a mechanic here
so trying to do everything from a
distance doesn't always work and i don't
have the long handle attachment to this
thing so
like range is a bit of an issue look at
that
look at this i don't know why i'm doing
it with that one when i could be doing
it this one and maybe less passes but
oh look at this precariousness look at
the danger i'm in
guys everybody look i'm in so much
danger there we go
it's about finding the right technique
for the right location
because there's obviously like i think
this is the best angle for a roof
because i can just sweep across it
and the beam just gets wider as i go
down and i'll have to reposition less
because sometimes the walking technique
is good sometimes
the just the sweeping technique is good
sometimes quick up downs
sometimes spot cleaning you know it's
about finding the right moments to bust
out your
true potential and skill well
i'm done apparently good job me i
did it i want a power washer that's so
intense that it literally blows me off
the roof every time i try to use it oh
god this keyboard
[Music]
okay and hop down and finish this wall
yes
get this all done yeah best angle best
angle i gotta think about the best angle
all the time
[Music]
what's weird is that the graffiti is
actually under all the grime so that
means people were here a long time ago
and
and if people were just living here with
that grime that kind of says a story
about how they're actually dead in
ghosts
i have no conclusion to that statement i
just made i'm just spouting random
[ __ ] at this point because i'm
i'm guessing my brain is so focused on
power washing that random words are just
exuding from my mouth
this would be a great stream game you
know this just be a fantastic game to
just stream and talk to people
endlessly and i might i might do that i
might actually do that
[Music]
this is the grime badness i need help
with my poor little play school
play school what does that even mean how
do dirt finder i got a real doozy for
you
when you can experimented it for us over
the recreational grounds
recreational grounds what does that even
mean what are you guys talking about how
did you guys get my number
look i do person to person gigs you guys
gotta stop giving away my numbers
i mean i guess business is good but i
literally only live for the wash
if anyone tries to give me any purpose
if anyone tries to get in the way of my
life
cut them out immediately
[Music]
i'd like to think that these videos only
get better the more refined my technique
gets when it comes down to power washing
just like the way that i do it must be a
certain type of satisfying and i want to
do right by you guys so i gotta make it
good
i gotta make it good for you guys
[Music]
almost done almost done surprisingly
almost done
if i had the longer attachment that one
might be a little easier
but i don't so i won't
[Music]
don't mean to be a debbie downer but
i've looked into the creepy symbols
you found on the side of the house
you're working on uh-oh
turns out that the builder's diagram is
selling the plumber
oopsies oh hey that was not clean i
wasn't done with that what the hell are
you doing
[Music]
oh god the stupid keyboard it just like
is so easy to press another button and i
really don't like it it's too claggy i
don't know why anyone makes mechanical
keyboards anymore they're just too
goddamn loud when i'm trying to record a
video i don't want a loud
keyboard bugging up everything and then
it's just too easy to press why is a
mechanical keyboard so easy to press
i hate this keyboard i hate it i just
did it again it's just like the lightest
it's it's like it'll press when it's not
even all the way down
why would you do that it's like the
lightest touch pushes it i don't want
that
i did this to myself i know god i hate
everything
i hate it so much i'm trying to enjoy a
nice power washing experience
and this thing keeps mucking it up
oh i guess i'm done with that i didn't
think i was
but i guess i'm done
i was not done i
was not done in any way shape or form
what was that i was so not done
oh you're robbing me game you're being
too
well not nice but you're trying to be
too forgiving all right what do we got
here
yes please thank you all right stay on
the ladder
okay stay on the ladder i'm not
touching it
[Music]
all right all right
oh now this one's being more picky why
is this one being more picky
hmm i'll probably the other side of it
yeah
ah oh what am i missing what am i
missing
chimney top okay bricks and chimney top
okay
got it got it got it chimney top oh i
see that
i see that i see that
okay and then bricks somewhere probably
down here
expects bricks bricks uh-huh
aha what else
gutter oh gutter there's a gutter not oh
this gutter is not done
how are you not done there we go there
it is there it is there it is
got it okay one more walls
and wood trims oh my god okay
[Music]
wall
[Music]
only took an hour only took a single
hour the house looks amazing almost
normal you know what strange as you were
finishing there was a screech from the
attic so i opened the latch and
something whoosh past my face grubby
gray feather floating mysteriously down
i think it was esther's soul
leaving finally finally at peace yeah
i'm sure
okay i'm sure uh what is that
clean the shoe house also the skate park
my god that would be a long job
um skatepark it is i guess in the old
days we'd fill a bucket and the children
would do it themselves top to bottom so
much fun and most of them came to know
most of them came to norm nowadays
they're not even allowed on the roof
never mind the guttering
before the parents get angry you could
come down give it a good wash
all right i'll wash this old boot ain't
you a sugar
that's nice it is to have play school in
the forest so this is what you meant by
play school
it's a school you you play in
interesting
very interesting um the job shouldn't
take too terribly long doesn't seem like
anything else is dirty besides the house
so let's just get to it then
let's give the whole thing a soak first
i mean it looks like pretty grimy so
there's gonna be a lot that needs to be
cleaned but
there's top to bottom soakage
[Music]
i mean that is some moss on the bottom
of that boot
i don't like that this boot also looks
like it's actually been stomping around
the forest a bit because that's a little
concerning
a little above my pay grade but uh
whatever
i know that a lot of what i'm doing
isn't always going to be the most
efficient method like i get that
but also just like i'm doing kind of a
way
that i enjoy like getting big and then
targeting
feels better that way for some reason i
don't know why
[Music]
you got a stinky butt butt wow thanks
that's really appreciated i can think of
a lot of logical explanations of why i
got that text like sure maybe someone's
kid got the
got the message but also i know people
in my life that would just text me that
out of the blue so i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna chalk it up to a kid
automatically doing that i'm gonna
assume it's tyler
i'm assuming that's tyler
oh that grime that grime
yeah can you imagine kids trying to do
this with a bunch of buckets hanging off
this school
yeah i don't want to criticize a school
it is quite small and i know out of a
fairy tale thing but just like
i can't imagine the ergonomics of the
interior this boot are gonna be very
good
not that i've ever been welcomed into
any of these places
i don't want the power washer man in
there
[Music]
oh oh oh look at that look at that
oh my god that's so handy i've gained a
new superpower i've got
dirk senses now my dirt since
i want a yogurt tube yeah it sounds like
tyler too you know
tyler just stop texting me while i'm at
work you gotta
you gotta ease up man i'm i'm busy i'll
get you
yogurt later johnny bit me well you know
tyler just bite johnny back i don't know
how to tell you this man but you can't
let that stand
yo you just gotta you gotta assert your
dominance tell tyler that he needs to
assert his dominance
and if he's incapable of doing that just
like express it to him in grunts
that's kind of a language that he he
understands if he acts confused he's
just trying to he's just playing
coy he knows exactly what you're talking
about
[Music]
wow that is very helpful
[Music]
i'm gonna poop i'm going poop yeah uh
tyler good job good job man real proud
of you
you go poop you go you go get him you go
get that poop you poop
you poop man real proud of you i don't
that's great man good job i'm proud of
you
oh man everyone should be so proud of
him
everyone should be so proud doc we found
a mucky old thing in our garage let us
know when you're free to come out over
and give it a wash
yeah i'll be done in a bit almost done
with this one
this one wasn't too bad
what was that grunt
what the hell what is that
ah
what is oh
why are there gnomes looking at me
pretty much everywhere
i never stopped to ponder the reality of
my
circumstances starting to realize that
maybe i should have been paying a bit
more attention but oh well i got a job
to finish
in a hurry now
[Music]
hey there we go soul's done
now we're making progress now we're
making progress now we're knocking it
all out okay we're making good progress
now
i'm so sorry about that tyler found my
phone hey i get it martha i get it
martha it happens
just don't let it happen again tyler's
not supposed to have mine
okay now i need to figure out how to get
up there give me that
give me that yeah okay perfect easy
[Music]
peasy
[Music]
there's some issues with this not quite
getting
clean still dirty everywhere
oh god it's so ah it's so dirty in here
how's anybody supposed to get this like
really in a nook
dare i say a cranny so i have to ask how
many of these
school children on the way to this
lovely uh
playhouse in the middle of the woods uh
how many of them got turned into pies
like if you had to give me an estimate
like an over under on the number of pies
that were crafted
from the various school children that
most
certainly went missing
almost guaranteed missing how many pies
it's got to be just this roof left right
there's got to be something left on no
the roof is done when did the roof get
done
oh how in the hell do i get all of the
nooks
and or crannies of that nothing glowing
nothing doing nothing
oh there we go okay okay all right what
are we missing
uh eyelets okay so the little uh shoe
eyes
okay eyelets are done and wooden trims i
knew there was going to be some wooden
trims left
oh my god there's no way where the hell
the goddamn
wooden trims yeah you wouldn't trimmy
bastards
i'm not seeing any that aren't done oh
my god
oh i'm gonna be here forever i'm gonna
be here forever
oh the only hope i have is just to wash
the whole
goddamn boot again oh wait i just saw
i thought i just saw it i thought i
thought i saw some yeah yeah yeah
okay that one maybe that one too
i don't know how i didn't oh you yeah
same one
okay ah it's cause i didn't look down on
this one i was too busy looking up oh
dab complete
our forest home puts the grots in grotto
could you come and give it to spring
clean
no not at all
oh my goodness oh i don't like that it
keeps the flashes in there
oh the flash just kind of ruined the
experience the flash has ruined the
experience can i
sell anything that's what i wish i could
do i wish i could sell
like my old stuff because there's no way
that i would go back to my light duty
one
but i want the prem prime vista oh i
want the pro
oh oh man none of these get oily
none of those get oily when am i gonna
see oily stuff
is that coming soon ooh vintage car
though oh that's not bad
that might have some oily stuff though
wash me yeah i'm working on it
oh man rust rust
oh how do you clean off rust
that must just be a soap thing
all right so i knew that there would be
things where there are mechanics that
i'm not really going to be able to get
with
just my power washer which is water
alone
i'm beginning to suspect that this might
not be a worthless heap
uh well yeah you know i'll i'll do my
best maybe we can split
you know the value of it this does seem
like quite an antique
you know probably would go for quite a
pretty penny you know what i mean
wink wink you thought it was worthless
i'm making it not worthless so
technically it's like uh my fault that
it's gonna be worth anything
i'm scrolling through the esther
archives online esther oh this is the
haunted house
oh this is a house that i cleaned before
oh the story continues no photos of her
with a car anywhere
that's a little concerning is this the
filth amendment
[Applause]
why do you keep saying the wrong name of
my freaking store
clear your diary this is a big job whole
fire station needs doing
this esther's last film drive me nuts oh
okay cool that's cool uh did the fire
station catch on fire is that why you
need me
how's this tire still not clean god damn
clean the goddamn tire
[Music]
the hell there we go must've been the
tip top
all right
[Music]
okay so i think i got everything except
for the rust and i don't know
oh this can get the rust but my god
that's slow
technically does work though i wish i
would have known this i would have just
gone in with this from the get-go
[Applause]
now rust is only affected by targeted
okay i see
i see what's going on the film shocking
finale
meant it was a flop and that's his final
role so sad looks like she got to keep
the car though that's good for her
whoever
esther is and i know their ghost is
still haunting me to this day i can feel
it
which is also great
[Music]
this might call for
the metal cleaner i mean
it's just like otherwise like this is
just going to take
forever and i know this is only a 200
job
200 job but look how much faster that is
like that's
it's this would be nightmarishly slow
otherwise
like this is clearly a job for
metal cleaner clearly okay there's
tiny tiny pieces missing of everything
good god oh my god get over yourself
get over yourself is this bumper still
not good oh my god get over yourself
there we go i don't think me
leaping up on this car is appropriate
for me trying to fix it all
there we go shelf
shell shelf
okay is that not everything wing mirrors
oh my god
wing mirror okay this wing mirror
oh god
such a pain in the ass
what a pain in that dong okay all right
with that it looks like i'm not going to
be able to get
a 100
the wash down live stream went viral so
we're hoping our new driving miss
pebbles series will add another 100k
subscribers to our channel so exciting
what about me what about my subscribers
okay so that's gonna be it for this one
um freaking fire station oh my god
that's a lot of money but
how would i ever do this how would i do
that
freaking skate park oh man but the skate
park would get me to the
oh it would get me to the new washer
even if i use some cleaners
but i'm not going to do it not in this
episode anyway it would take me way way
way too long and i don't have that kind
of time so thank you everybody so much
for watching
let me know what you thought down the
comments below if you want more of this
i am going to hold off now or i'm going
to do live stream of it i have no idea
what i'm going to do now
but thank you guys so much for watching
and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]